I was like 5 years old while I'm sitting  on my father's lap it's got me propped  up at both my hands are on the steering  wheel and he kept going faster and  faster  I remember hearing him laughing faster  we went happier he was how are you again  5 my mom taught me has dry  your mom yeah man  I was right before she left though you  know hate her for that but I can't  either completely you know first time I  drove was of my learner's permit when we  were on the 44 you as my mother and I  car in front of you locks up its brakes  oh no boom someone blew into me from  behind five car pileup first time I  drove before my dad went away bought me  this 71 Malibu classic first dad got my  license it's the greatest day salsa the  first day that I had sex I [ __ ] you not  something about learning how to drive  what it's you you're a driver well  you're not a driver so up until the  point you start driving it's one  lifetime and then after you start  driving isn't no